5 25 on your Monday morning you know
there's a viewer who missed the
responses to that long-running driving
you crazy email chain Ruth writes I
never heard the answers when someone
asked why at a stoplight do people at a
space of one to two cars happen in front
of them she says I could drive sideways
through these nuts Ruth I got more
emails about this than almost everything
else besides the Speeders uh slow
drivers in the fast lane also cars with
expired tags or no tags
most of the responses though were along
the lines of one car length between cars
is a safety precaution I've been
rear-ended don't want to slam into the
car in front of me viewer Brad expanded
on the financial implications say a car
hits you from behind causing you to hit
the person in front of you making you
buy him a new car and who knows if the
guy that hit you has Insurance to fix
your car or your front person's car do
you have thousands of dollars to buy the
guy in front a car and pay 70 grand for
their medical bills
Terry who says I'm not a psychologist
theorized that it could be a
subconscious transference of drivers
social distancing
we'll close with Linda who may be nailed
it on why the Wide Open Spaces in a
hurry to stop and text everyone's head
looking down at their crotch at a signal
okay Ruth thanks for writing in now I've
got links to all of those previous
stories in the online version of this
story when you visit our website and
click traffic then drive a new crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone now you can join in on
this driving you crazy conversation at
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com